hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game uh it's from the blood
super tournament of 1961 and it's a game
from round six it's a former world
champion tigran petrossian uh versus
ludek pachmann uh he was a german
czechoslovakian grandmaster
and this is uh this is really a beauty
the game comes as a suggestion from a
subscriber
narayanan s uh so thank you for that i i
have not seen this game yet i might have
seen it like somewhere you know
um while passing by but never
really started it and this is such an
amazing tournament that
i hope we are going to cover it in its
entirety at some point
uh but i decided to still show this game
just to give you a glimpse of
what you can expect in this tournament
so like i said uh blood super tournament
of 1961
uh featured some extraordinary players
here uh we even have uh
uh well uh sorry about that it's a whoa
uh it's not
the greatest of photos but these are all
of the participants of the tournament
uh if anyone can make out who all of
these uh
uh guys are uh definitely share in the
comment section i will pin your comment
but we're
from the uh some uh that can be spotted
a little bit easier
uh there's fisher i think all the way on
the right then there's gligorich next to
him there's uh
uh i i cannot recognize the two
gentlemen then there's tigran uh uh the
the fifth from from left
then we also see misha misha is in the
middle uh
and uh well a lot of players here keras
is there on the right
uh i see geller in the back uh well okay
you can make out most of them but if
anyone can make up uh
make out all of them do share and also
there's this very nice photo
of them sharing a meal and this is very
tricky here
on the left uh okay i don't know who the
first gentleman is the second one is
paul karas
and then there's geller uh uh uh
uh uh two two people after keras but
there's this gentleman in between that
looks like a
uh like a fusion of uh petrossian and
tal
uh so it's if any of you can make out
whether that's actually petrossian or
tal that that'd be great but
it can be like either of them uh but it
does seem to be like it's both of them
so that being said let's check out this
very nice game and
why it was suggested so uh tigran with
the white pieces opens with knight to f3
he starts with a retti opening
uh we have c5 by black uh and or this is
the so-called invitation to a sicilian
defense defense if white wants to maybe
transpose with e4 into a sicilian
uh but uh tigran goes for g3 he prepares
the fiance to his light square bishop
castle and so on
so knights to c6 we have bishop to g2
and now
g6 preparing the fiance to the dark
square bishop uh we have castles and the
bishop to g7
uh we have d3 uh e6 by black and
now uh e4 grabbing more space in the
center
knight g to e7 black also prepares the
castle and now
rook to e1 we have castles and now
e5 uh here if this was played
probably nowadays c3 would be would be
the more common move here but here
we have e5 grabbing more space in the
center and
black immediately challenges that he
plays d6 puts pressure on the
e5 pawn and white trades we have
captures captures and now
knight b to d2 so the e4 square has been
vacated and now the knight is coming to
e4 so queen back to c7
and the knight now comes to b3 puts
pressure on the c5 pawn
and also as g3 has been played you are
ready to play bishop to f4 to put
pressure on the queen so
you want to develop your pieces with
tempo so here not that
black goes knight to d4 black offers a
trade of knights and also now the queen
defends the c5 pawn
uh so tigran continues developing with
bishop to f4 attacking the queen on c7
and here queen to b6 is played here you
could
you should actually play knight captures
an f3 and i thought this was weird why
not capture the knight and then play e5
just uh uh you know move that bishop out
of the way
the the thing is after capturing
captures and d5
it seems like after bishop to e3 you are
losing the c5 pawn but not
because you can't play b6 the rook would
be hanging here but
you could decide to give up upon rook b8
and then
you know try and try and uh exploit this
for example if bishop captures you're
going to play b6 and then you play
bishop to b7 trade of the light square
bishop
maybe try and start started an attack so
it's upon sacrifice but maybe
maybe uh one that could have been played
but okay uh bachmann goes for queen to
b6 instead and now comes
knight to e5 and here is the
already a very very interesting moment
in the game uh here
although it looks um like it doesn't
really matter bishop captures on e5 is
what you want to play
captures captures and f6 okay you've
played f6 but uh
you push back the the bishop or you you
force a trade here then you're gonna
play e5 and everything is
fine for black and this is probably what
pachmann had in mind but
the problem is he captured on b3 first
thinking that
okay uh after tigran captures on b3 i'm
only then gonna capture on e5 but
here uh is where things start to go
wrong for black here
tyrone goes knight to c4 and this comes
with tempo the queen is now under attack
so he will not be trading the knight on
e5
uh and as bobby fischer also annotated
this game fisher says that this is a
very nice tempo move
so here after knight to c4 queen to b5
and only now do you recapture on b3 so a
captures on b3 and
now a5 by black we have bishop to d6 by
tigran going after the knight here
also the knight cannot move as the rook
would be under attack so bishop to f6
defending the knight and now comes queen
to f3
attacking the bishop here and it seems
like it's perfectly fine but i mean
black can defend this
just king to g7 and everything is fine
and this is in fact
uh what pachmann played but now there's
a there's a real problem here
here black's position is completely lost
uh and
even though you could go for it right
away we're going to get back to this
position after i show you the game here
tiger first played uh a rook e4 and rook
the e4 is a deadly preparation move
uh fisher also says that now a beautiful
finish is in order
uh the the thing is that now the rook
controls the entire fourth rank and this
is a very very important uh here we have
rook to d8 as you don't want to rook on
f8 you want to
move the rook so you can start moving
the knight so here rook to d8 was played
but now the game is actually completely
lost it's uh
forced checkmate in seven for for tigran
so feel free to pause the video here and
uh you know
win the game in great style while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
finding the second greatest queen
sacrifice on f6 uh you'll know which is
the first one
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's queen captures on f6
this comes with the check
and the queen sacrifice simply must be
accepted if you move the king let's say
you try king the g8
then just rook to f4 and you are you are
getting destroyed if rook to f8
then just bishop to e8 and again there
is no defending against mate
so you have to capture the queen but
even if it wasn't checkmate you just
lost a piece so you you kind of have to
capture the queen so here king captures
on f6
and now comes bishop to e5 check this is
the
uh the the beautiful move uh as now the
king has to come uh come down the board
the g7 has been uh defended by the
bishop so here
king the g5 and now uh the move that uh
probably got fischer's attention the
most is uh
tignan's next move so once again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the quickest way for whites to win this
there are many ways but the quickest one
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations uh
if you found the first one as well then
double congratulations uh and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's the beautiful bishop to g7 this is
the move that
seals the deal because now the king is
cut off from both
f6 and h6 squares and now there is
nothing to be done here
and it was in fact in this position on
move 21 that ludic pachmann resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done
here so all of these squares are taken
away from the black king the rook
covers this entire rank and uh after
that moves like
f495 h4 are coming and you're just
getting checkmated to give you a very
uh simple example for example if e5 you
try and open up let's say the the light
square bishops diagonal maybe even try
and vacate some squares for for the king
uh it doesn't help just h4 and now uh if
king to f5 then bishop to h3 is
checkmate that's the
that's the good stuff and of course if
you go king to h5 then you get bishop to
f3
check and after a bishop to g4 that
doesn't really matter just bishop
captures and this is again checkmate
but it's very interesting even before uh
tigran captured here uh
rook to the eighth was played and then
sacrificed the queen with uh queen to f6
uh the position is completely winning
even without this uh
rook to e4 move although uh
it's easy to understand that tigran's uh
approach to this
the position is completely winning for
white and you don't want to take any
chances
uh but just to show you uh that bishop
to e4 is not necessary you could
just capture on f6 right away and then
after king captures the same idea
applies bishop to e5 king g5 bishop to
g7
uh the star move uh but now it is a bit
different because you don't have the
rook
cutting of the king from the from the
fourth rank but still it doesn't matter
whatever you play you're just lost for
example
if f5 you can just play f4 with check
and now you have to still go down the
board king g4
knights the e3 check king to h5 and now
for example bishop to f3 will be
checkmate but uh
there's a lot more to consider so rook
to e4 is just a very practical decision
by tigran
uh asked so he doesn't have to calculate
all that much
uh so that's uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it and
here are the if you're if you guys are
interested as we are going to cover this
tournament in its entirety at some point
uh these are the final standings of the
1961
blood super tournament it's not
petrossian who won the tournament but it
was
actually the the pirate of riga the the
magician
uh mikhail won the tournament one full
point ahead of bobby fischer
uh there you can see 14 and a half to
fisher 13 and a half
and interestingly as you can see uh
fisher
uh finished the tournament without a
loss fischer has eight wins
zero losses and eleven draws but misha
uh
defeated more players he has 11 wins one
loss and uh
seven draws but interestingly the only
game uh
misha lost in this tournament is the
bobby fischer uh which is all the
more impressive that he was able to
clinch first
place ahead of bobby even though even
though he lost him but definitely a
tournament that we are going to cover
entirely so uh you know i hope you guys
will enjoy that as well
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed that and a little bit of history
behind the tournament uh
photos of course if you guys uh you know
can can make out who
this gentleman is wiping his mouth then
that that'd be great
uh i would like to thank a mystery
person uh mark murray darius
barkovsky olsen and david durbin for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do keep using hashtag suggestions so you
can find many many more games
such as this one see you soon